mach ich schluss würde jetzt cdu wählen
nein es gibt nichts was für die cdu
spricht
ich glaube es hat vielleicht auch das
problem dass sie so ich weiß nicht ich
finds halt so fällt sieger also ich bin
total viel fake was sie machen könnte
die cdu die irgendwie bestechen dass du
so willst wenn die cdu grafs verteilen
würde da mal weißt du da da gehen sie
dann mal auf wissenschaftliche studien
und sagen sie ja gras so schlecht gras
ist dies das alvesse aber auch die
ganzen wissenschaftlichen studien zu
klima oder co2 oder sonstiges gehen sie
nicht an oder was und jetzt zur
wahlparty der cdu csu
strategisch clever hat man die junge
union in der ersten reihe geparkt
ich sehe alle beiden jungen wähler der
cdu sind heute zum mitfeiern gekommen
ein paar mehr als wir schon sind sie so
gut gelaunt wenn man sich sagt ach naja
war ja nur europa hat die bremen wahl
ist doch gut
ja aber wenn man das mal abwägt europa
bremen
glauben sie dass die jugend die cdu
heute abgestraft hat sehen sie die cdu
stärkste partei geworden
wir haben gesehen dass unsere partei für
und gesagt hat dass wir manche mängel
haben und dass wir manche mängel haben
kann ich nur unterstreichen
wir müssen als union insgesamt daran
arbeiten wieder jünger cola offener zu
werden ist die cdu cool das ist so eine
sache
was verstehen sie aber jetzt bei politik
und der cool
haben sie mal den robert habeck gesehen
die annalena baerbock
die cool sind doch cool oder denken sie
wenn sie nicht also wenn die kult sind
dann bin ich ja auch das hier so wie sie
die cdu ist cool nach wie vor
man sollte nur die jungen mehr
einbeziehen und auf youtube auch mehr zu
hören
genau so und ich würde jetzt um das
ganze noch zu steigern dass wir da auch
wirklich coolen effekt kriegen würde ich
beatboxen und sie machen das dann im
takt nochmal die cdu ist cool genau also
auf 31 23
die cdu ist cool und sollte mehr auf
junge leute hören das kann die cdu
machen um die jungen leute wieder
einzufangen
also bestimmt der social media auftritt
müsste ein bisschen besser sein also ja
wir brauchen halt wahrscheinlich junge
leute wie viel also naja ist ja
offiziell
ich will nur eins sagen wenn riese in
seinem zweiten video gesagt hat
das ist ein konsens über eine
wissenschaftliche erkenntnis gibt ist
das ein anspruch auf allgemeingültigkeit
und richtigkeit die in der demokratie
ablehnen
also wenn jemand sagt 99,8 prozent der
studien sagen dass der klimawandel
menschengemacht ist
dann kann man nicht sagen alle studien
besagen dass so würden sie es nicht auf
und wir haben ja erhebliche
anstrengungen unternommen
gegen den klimawandel es ist so sie
können doch nicht sagen dass in den
letzten 30 jahren nicht erhebliche
umweltschutz gemerkt man sie können
sagen da ist nicht genug gemacht worden
das war also werden sie sagen dass gar
nichts gemacht worden ist und das ist
schlicht dumm
das habe ich nicht gesagt natürlich
haben sie das zum ausdruck was nicht
gesagt es ist nichts gemacht worden es
nicht genug gemacht worden
da sind wir doch alle auf derselben
auffassung und zu sagen wir doch auch
willig
darunter ist aber warum machen sie das
nicht mehr machen mehr wir haben mehr
als alle anderen gemacht in dieser welt
aber wenn wir mehr machen als andere
länder entschuldigt das doch nicht dass
deutschland seine eigenen klimaziele
reist wir haben druck zu machen dass sie
erreicht werden und werden das in vielen
gründen erreichen und das machen wir
große fortschritte und gleichzeitig
wollen wir auch dass der arbeitsplatz
ihres vaters erhalten bleibt herzlichen
vater ist lehrer durch die unter
studienorganisation das komplott der
strom aus der steckdose
ja vielleicht doch ganz gut dass elmar
brok nicht mehr im eu parlament ist und
damit zurück ins studio
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünscht
überall lassen die ihre techniken liegen
und hier last jetzt das xenix ein
beschissenes ab
[Musik]